Wow. So, um,
this my last true confession to you,
my class.
Um, and is it true I always
give you true confessions.
I never lied to you in my class. Um, but
this is a truly true confession because,
um,
the fact of the matter is I actually
really couldn't figure out how to end the
course.
Like I can figure out what this last
lecture was supposed to be and I really
wondered about it. Agonized
over it. It's the last lecture.
There's all this pressure,
you know, sell up.
Several of you have emailed me and said,
looking forward to the last lecture.
And it's like, how can I live
up to the expectation? Um,
so I decided that,
um,
I would do two things in the lecture.
Um,
and the first thing that I'm going to
do is talk about the end of the American
revolution,
which is not an easy thing to do.
And I'm not going to be so good as to
actually put my finger on the moment when
the revolution ends,
but I'm at least going to suggest
a couple things about that.
And then at the end,
you'll see I'm going to come back around
and hopefully magically just tie the
whole course together.
By the end of the lecture,
you will for sure notice that some of
the things I'm talking about now have
references to things I talked about
way at the beginning of the course.
So I'm trying for
symmetry course symmetry.
And if you think back in the
distant ages of time, um,
when this course started,
um, I talked on that first,
I think the very first lecture I did,
um,
I used to quote from John Adams and
I used a quote from Benjamin Rush.
Those are the quotes that are
on the top of this syllabus. Um,
and both of them talk about when
the revolution supposedly began.
So Adam's writing an 1815 said that he
thought the revolution began in the minds
of the people.
And this was affected from 1760 to 1775
in the course of 15 years before a drop
of blood was drawn at Lexington.
So he says the war quote was
no part of the revolution.
And then the other quote I read was rush,
who in 1776 basically agreed that the
war and the revolution were two different
things, but then says, um,
the American war is over.
But this is far from being the
case with the American revolution.
We have changed our forms of government,
but it remains to affect a revolution
of our principals opinions and manners.
So as to accommodate that them to the
forms of government we have adopted. Okay.
So when I quoted those at the
very beginning of the course,
I basically was quoting them to kind of
shake up your assumptions about what the
American revolution actually was. You
know, if the founders can't even agree,
that kind of opens things broadly
for us to really talk about what the
revolution was today.
I'm mentioning them because I actually
do want us to think a little bit about if
that is, it is all that
confusion about when it starts,
what can we say about
when a revolution ends?
And there's definitely a hint about
how to discuss that question in both of
those quotes,
even though they don't necessarily agree.
Because both men and one way or
another saw the revolution as being
fundamentally about what
rush called principles,
opinions and manners and Adams called
a change in the minds of the people.
So in a way, they're both
saying that a real revolution,
a full revolution involves some kind
of a fundamental change in principals.
And as both men suggest, obviously this
isn't something that happens instantly,
like a declaration of war or
a surrender on a battlefield.
But it's a process and it takes place
over years, maybe even over decades.
Now obviously if you think about what
a revolution is formerly speaking,
it's a change of forms, forms of
government more than anything else.
So it involves some kind of a large scale
transfer of power after some kind of a
struggle between competing groups,
right?
So it's like a major shift
in sovereignty of some kind.
But for the struggle and the instability
of the revolution to come to a close,
obviously there had to be some kind of
a shared agreement about the nature of
whatever this new regime was going to
be about. What it's ideals were about,
what it's shape was going to be.
And without that kind of shared
agreement on those kinds of things,
this new regime would really stay in a
state of flux and would be vulnerable to
all kinds of continued dramatic and
potentially revolutionary change.
So in a sense,
what I'm saying here is that revolutions
involve both deconstruction and
reconstruction and that basically it's
one thing to rebel against something and
it's quite another thing to construct
something in its place that manages to get
some kind of general acceptance.
And a revolution cannot be said to have
ended until both parts of that equation
have been met.
And I think if you think back
over the course of the semester,
you can see that during the semester
we've looked at both parts of that
equation.
In a sense.
We've looked at the very beginning of
the course when we were getting towards
the beginning of the war.
We've seen how Americans generally
agreed about what they were protesting
against.
But the 1770 1780 1790s revealed,
they've weren't necessarily in agreement
about what they were fighting for.
They didn't necessarily agree about what
the most desirable outcome would be.
And we've watched this over
the course of the semester.
We've seen people basically just figuring
out what this new regime is going to
be.
So we looked at the 1770s we saw how
people tried to create constitutions that
would reflect whatever this
new regime was going to be.
And we saw how those constitutions
pretty much distrusted centralized power.
Unfortunately at the 70s,
eighties revealed that that first
wave of reform wasn't quite right,
but there were some pretty important
problems that weren't solved,
that there was some new problems that
seem to be erupting that maybe hadn't been
anticipated before.
And then we've seen the result,
we watched continental army officers
sort of vaguely threatening some kind of
coup. And so the, the, the mighty power
of George Washington's glasses. Um,
we saw soldiers digging their bandits
through the windows of the Pennsylvania
State House to demand their pay
from the Confederation Congress.
We saw indebted farmers and Massachusetts
joining and protest to close down the
courts.
And then of course we saw the independent
republic of Vermont and my favorite,
the state of Franklin.
So clearly there was some
pretty widespread discontent
and some of the elite
also as we heard,
were not particularly happy.
Many of them wanted some
kind of economic stability.
Some of them were none too pleased
about what they saw as this sort of
widespread social instability.
So in one way or another,
all of these groups felt that the promise
of the revolution wasn't really being
fulfilled.
And the political system that had been
put into place during the revolution not
only was incapable of
dealing with the problem,
but in many ways it was fueling
the problem. Now, of course,
everything in one way or another
added up to lead to the constitutional
convention, which we discussed. Um,
and as we discussed in the course,
a new constitution was by no
means a done deal. And in fact,
there was some pretty fervent debate over
whether or not some individual states
even wanted to participate in
the whole convention at all.
And we've seen some of what people were
scared of in those debates about whether
or not to go to the convention,
a stronger government or even just the
new government might open the door to
things like an established aristocracy,
monarchy,
tyrannical centralized power,
the rise of a privileged few,
over an impoverished many.
So in essence,
these people are seeing that there
might be a big change happening.
They don't know what the change is
going to be and anything seems possible.
And all of those things obviously
would represent going back on what the
revolution had just gone forth for.
So in essence,
you see people who had absolutely no sense
of political stability or permanence,
no sense of what was going to come,
no real consensus about
the best way to fix it.
Now following the 1780s came a period
that obviously we don't cover in this
course.
My other electric cars covers
it and that's the 1790s
which saw yet another wave
of reform.
And this time it has to do with the
rise of the federalist Party and the
federalists and one way or another
were largely about centralizing power.
Even more and strengthening the national
government even more and controlling
and channeling the protest and
politicking of the populace.
They're not all that comfortable
with ongoing popular politicking.
And here again, in the 1790s
with this sort of counter wave,
you also see more instability,
more of a sense that there's some kind
of potentially drastic change that might
be happening just around the
corner. So throughout the 17, nine,
these people have things in their letters,
throw away lines like if this
government last another five years,
here's what I think we should do.
Um,
you can almost feel in some of these
letters how frightened in a sense some of
these people were who were stepping onto
the stage of a new government in this
sense of amazing instability. I'm going
to offer three quotes because it's,
it's amazing to me how similar they are.
They all use the same image.
It's almost like they
went into a room and said,
how should we describe being
scared in 1789? Oh, I know. Um,
so James Madison says in 1789,
we are in a wilderness without
a single footstep to guide us.
George Washington in 1790 I walk on
untrodden ground and good old Pennsylvania
Senator William McClay who offered us
that quote way at the beginning of the
course sitting next to Virginians at
dinner and saying that all they talked
about was alcohol and horses.
Um,
Mclean says the whole world is a shell
and we tread on hollow ground every step.
Now that's kind of interesting to me that
all of those quotes are all saying the
same thing, which is basically
all of these guys literally
are saying, wow, I'm on,
is really unstable ground and I have no
idea where I'm supposed to be going or
what a safe pack is going to be.
So throughout the 1790s the federalists
countered their sense of social disorder
by trying to legislate and administrate
their way into order and control.
And the alien and sedition acts of 1798
which I'm sure you probably studied in
high school, are two of the most
extreme examples along those lines.
This brings us to Thomas Jefferson and
the presidential election of 1800 now
significantly for the purposes of
this class. Jefferson years later,
very modestly called his own
election to the presidency,
quote the revolution of 1800
right? Not Modest at all. Oh yes.
When I came to power, it was the
revolution of 1800 and not only that,
he said it was as real a revolution in
the principles of our government as that
of 1776 was in its form. Okay.
He's talking serious revolution.
My rise to power was just as significant
as 1776 thank you Thomas Jefferson,
but you can kind of see that given what
was happening in the 1790s in my like
amazingly quick and dirty frighteningly
condensed version of the 70 nineties
that I just gave you, given what
the federalists seemed to represent,
you could see why Jefferson would have
thought that his rise to the presidency
was some kind of a return to core
principles or revolutionary principles.
Now this change of principles wasn't easy.
And actually I think it was the whole
intensity of the experience of that 1800
election that led Jefferson to
experience and describe his election as a
revolution that was fought and won.
His rise to the presidency came after
a seemingly deadlocked tie vote in the
electoral college that was thrown into
the House of Representatives to decide.
So deadlocked was the election.
And so extreme where the
fears and expectations on
all sides that if the wrong
person got the office,
the entire nation would come crashing
to ruin that two states in two different
states. And in one state, I
believe the governor was in on it.
People were stockpiling arms because they
were going to march on Washington and
take the government for Jefferson.
Yeah, that's, that's amazing.
That's America in a sense on the
brink of some sort of civil war.
If the people are marching
on the government to take
it for the person who they
think should be Jared, it
should be president. Um,
Massachusetts federalist Fisher Ames at
that time fought about this and believe
that he understood why this was happening.
And I'll,
I'll mention here only because it's
been a continuing theme in our course.
We've seen lots of crying
guys over the semester.
Washington's really good at reducing
people to tears apparently. Um,
and I have to mention here partly because
I just really liked Fisher ames cause
he's sort of an intriguing character
who always says quotable things. Um,
but he also,
he was in congress in the 1790s and the
thing that he's most known for is he
made a speech about the Jay Treaty
and everybody started to cry.
So he reduced congress to tears,
which to me is kind of a terrifying image.
Congress crying.
So Fisher Ames,
mighty orator reduce her to tears.
Um,
here's what he says in 1800 when he's
looking around and he's trying to figure
out what this all means,
the fat really is that there is a want
of accordance between our system of
government and the state
of our public opinion.
The government is Republican
opinion is essentially democratic.
Either events,
we'll raise public opinion high enough
to support our government or public
opinion will pull down the
government to its own level.
They must equalize.
That's really interesting.
So here watching what's happening in 1800
aims is kind of confirming what Adams
and rush were suggesting and the quotes
that I started out by discussing for a
revolution to end forms and public
opinion have to equalize in some way and
before they do things remain unstable.
So in a way,
what all of these guys are saying is
that revolutions end when public opinion
conforms with new post
revolutionary forms of governance.
And until that happens, revolutionary
change is still entirely possible.
Once that happens,
once the sort of new car smell is
dissipated from a new government and the
government could be taken for granted,
is kind of the normal state of affairs
and it's endorsed by a majority,
then it becomes much harder to stage
some kind of full scale revolution from
outside of the government.
So in essence,
revolutions and when the public
mind declares that they do,
it's up to the public.
Now that's a nice big,
broad general discussion about defining
the bounds of the American revolution.
But what does that really mean?
Like,
what are we really saying
here and how can we show it?
How do you actually show public opinion
changing and eventually conforming with
the new government? Well, what
am I that you can begin to do?
This is to find a wonderful primary source
that includes all kinds of eyewitness
testimony about one person's ideas
and how they changed over time.
So I bring to you today the recorded
recollections of George rubber,
twelves Hughes,
a New England shoemaker.
I know he's popped up once or twice in
one or two of the books we've read and
he's popped up once or twice for
good reason because it's hard.
It's harder to find comments from
people who are not lofty founders.
It's hard to find recollections and
memories and thoughts about the revolution
in a broad sense from average
Americans because number one,
they don't spend a lot of time off
and sitting down and losing on paper.
And number two,
their papers don't get saved as often as
an elite politicians papers get saved.
So people always quote George Robert
twelves Hughes because he's there and he's
thoughtful.
And he actually went back and talked
about his entire life and his life spans
this entire period.
He was born in 1742 he dies in 1840
so he lives a really long time.
And he ended up being one of the last
surviving veterans of the revolution,
or at least that people knew about.
So because of that in the 1830s he was
interviewed so that he could talk about
his recollections, things of his life
that he saw as being significant.
So let's look for a minute
at what Hughes can show us.
For one thing you can see in some of the
stories that he told and the way that
he tells them some kind of subtle but
actually pretty significant changes in the
public mind that were unleashed
by the revolution. So for example,
one of his earliest memories was of
having to bring a pair of shoes to John
Hancock. And as he recalled the occasion,
all these years later, he was terrified.
And he says he's first ushered into the
kitchen where his type of person belongs.
And then Hancock says, no, no, actually
I'd like to thank this guy personally.
So then he's ushered into the sitting
room and he mumbles a little speech.
He didn't quite know what he was
supposed to say or how to say it and he's
really embarrassed. And then Handcock
actually ask him to sit down,
which terrifies him even more. And
then worst of all, Handcock says,
let me drink to your health and wants
to do the whole glass clinking thing.
And he says,
I'd never done the glass clinking thing.
I didn't know what I was doing.
We did the glass clinking thing and
then he basically ran away as soon as he
could without being rude.
Now he was Mary of this whole episode.
Even all of these years later shows
really sort of colonial era difference at
work or this is not someone who's
just respectful of John Hancock.
This is someone who is
scared of interacting with
someone who that above him in
society
now.
He's lived in Boston and the 1760s and
seventies seventies this is very handy
for us obviously because then he offers
us eye witness testimony about other
kinds of sort of floating
in the air opinions that
we're developing at the time.
So he certainly, you can see when
he's talking about his experiences,
shared the feelings of many
of his neighbors in Boston
in the 1770s in his later
years,
he remembered how much he really hated
the British soldiers that were occupying
Boston.
He actually remembered that one of them
had a pair of shoes made and then never
paid for them. So it's a really
specific, I hate the British memory.
He also remembers watching an 18th
century mugging in which I'm a soldier,
knocked a lady down and stole
her bonnet and stole her MF.
So he remembers ugly British
soldier moments from Boston.
And then on March 5th he says that
when he heard noise in the street,
he ran to see what was happening and he
saw British soldiers firing on American
civilians and his response really say
something because he immediately ran home
to arm himself. He grabbed a cane
and he ran back to the uproar.
And when a soldier tried to
grab the cane out of his hands,
he was insistent that he had a
right to carry whatever he pleased.
Now that's really interesting
because here you see Hughes,
he's defending his fellow
Bostonians literally and
physically, and he's clearly,
I suppose an insisting that he has a right
to hold on to that cane defending his
rights to. But what you see is that
he's taken action almost instinctively.
It's not like he saw what was happening
and said, this is a revolutionary moment.
I must go home and grab my club so that
I can say I was there at the beginning
phases of the American
revolution. I mean, he, he,
he just sees what's happening in the
street. He's upset. It's his neighbors.
It's people from Boston who are getting
shot at and he instinctively is just
drawn in to what's happening.
So clearly his sense of involvement
and unfolding events is growing,
particularly given that he next
took part in the Boston tea party.
Obviously that's a very deliberate
choice to take part in a protest.
And then he fights as a
soldier during the revolution,
which I guess is the ultimate way in which
you show that you're part of a cause.
And then he went back to being a shoemaker
and then he became an aged veteran of
the revolution.
Oh,
and one thing I can't help mentioning
only because whenever I talk about George,
Robert twelves Hughes,
I always mention this because I just
love the fact that it exists. Um, he had,
I think, well actually I
know he had 15 children. Um,
but what's wonderful about
that fact is that, um,
his 11th son was named 11 and his,
his 15th son was named 15.
And I just love the guy,
George Robert twelves
Hughes has the humor.
I don't know if his sons were really
thrilled about being named 11 and 15. Um,
but I just love the fact that he did
this and that we know that that makes me
even happier. Okay. So,
so what does his show us besides
very bizarre naming habits? Um,
for one thing,
his recollections offer a great example
of the ways in which the revolution
inspired average Americans
to become politically active.
He was literally drawn into the action
first defending his neighbors and his
town,
but over time,
obviously feeling like he was taking
part in some kind of a larger cause.
So in essence, he helps us see how the
revolution could politicize someone.
And you kind of see this in action.
Obviously with the Hancock story,
you could see what a real
sense of pre-revolutionary
difference felt like. Now,
of course, the revolution didn't
just stamp out difference,
but a politicized public was a public
that understood that it had rights and
that it could demand them.
And eventually the American people
would not show that kind of fear and
trembling before a member
of the supposed elite.
So basically eventually the
American public would find
their voice and this idea
that the public had a voice and had a
right to express it is the sort of general
changing of public opinion that would
ultimately connect to the nation's new
form of government.
So basically you see the sort of
beginning of a chain reaction that might
actually lead to the
end of the revolution.
You can see patterns unfolding that
represent pretty major changes over a long
stretch of time.
Now obviously it's not just average
American citizens who are being shaped by
the revolution. The elite were
profoundly effected by it as well.
And for one obvious thing,
suddenly they were presented with this
opportunity to create and shape a new
government for a new nation.
And they knew that this was
a pretty rare opportunity.
So even as they're doing it,
they know that this is not
something that happens very often.
Just listen to how John Adams discussed
what he felt like was the change that he
experienced over the course of his life.
And this is in one of the letters I
mentioned this at the beginning of the
course. These great letters they
write to each other in their old age.
So here writing to Jefferson,
Adam says, when I was young,
the summa Bonem or the sort of ultimate
height in Massachusetts was to be worth
10,000 pounds.
Sterling ride in a chariot or carriage,
be a kernel of a regiment of militia and
hold a seat in His Majesty's Council.
No Man's imagination aspire to
anything higher beneath the skies.
So Adams is thinking back and he's here
basically suggesting that the revolution
and its aftermath expand the
horizons of an entire generation.
Now he's talking about the elite,
but you could expand this to include
the American citizenry as well.
Cause then a variety of ways.
The revolution shook things up.
And in doing so it
expanded People's horizons.
Now I use the word citizenry and I
did that really deliberately. Um,
because all Americans did not have
their horizons expanded during the
Revolutionary War.
And this is something clearly we talked
about in class and you've talked about
in sections that's linked to some of
the discussions that we've been having
about how radical the
revolution was or wasn't.
So the elite, like everyone else, we're
profoundly effected by the revolution.
But of course they're not the people
who get to decide the fate of the
revolution. If the American public
who gets to make that decision,
it's their opinions of the new government
that are going to either make or break
the government and the revolution.
And during the period
covered by this course,
we've seen the beginnings of a long
period during which public opinion would
continue to change sometimes really
dramatically concerning just what this new
government and this new
nation was supposed to be.
Now I'm not going to end by continuing
here to talk about the end of the
revolution because it isn't
just the events of the
revolution that mattered even
when they're ending.
It's actually how we remember them.
That matters because the way that
we remember history obviously really
determines its meaning and its impact.
So basically history and how we
understand our history can have a profound
effect on the here and now. In a way,
this is what Jefferson referred to,
I think a couple of lectures back.
I talked about the dead hand of the past.
Jefferson wanting to like every 19
years, let's make a new constitution. Um,
that's kind of linked to that Jeffersonian
idea of the dead hand of the past.
And since history could have
that impact on the present,
depending on how you understand
it and that dead hand of the past,
it can be a pretty heavy hand
at this point. Basically,
I need, I need, I need
to tell you an anecdote.
I actually do need to
tell you an anecdote. Um,
as I was reading the lecture this morning,
um,
I was writing about the
dead hand of the past.
And I guess whenever I use that phrase,
I think at this one particular letter
I found, which actually is relevant,
so I'm not being completely random.
Um,
it does have something to do with the
dead hand of the past and history.
It actually also has nothing to
do with the American revolution,
but it really shows you how the past can
have an enormous weight on the present.
And it's also just an amazing little
piece of paper that I found and it has to
do with this letter that I found when
I was rummaging through, um, the,
the Addams family correspondence,
which is indeed what it's called,
the Addams family. So the, the
John Adams family correspondence,
and I found this letter from John
Quincy Adams. I wasn't looking for it,
but I found this letter
and he was overseas, uh,
when his father was running for president.
And he clearly,
he really wants to know if his father one,
and it takes a long time for
news to make it across the ocean.
So what I found was first one
letter in which he's writing,
do you know what happened in the election?
And then I found a lot of them and he
keeps me writing to people and writing to
people saying, do you know, do you
know, has my father won the election?
Who's won the election? What's happened
in the election? So I can't help.
But now I'm like following the trail
because I have to find the letter where he
finds out. Right. And you would assume,
I assumed that I found that letter.
He would say something, you know like,
ah, this is a great day for America,
or I don't know, something, something
lofty and you know, w vision,
this sort of looking out,
aw, junk with the Adams ask.
So finally I find the letter and I'm
going to paraphrase it and with my own bad
paraphrasing here, but the point
will be true. He basically says,
Oh God,
I'll never live up to this.
The first thing he thinks is now I'm
going to have to be president too.
That was amazing to me.
Like I really felt for John Quincy Adams,
like you suddenly got a quick flash
of what it felt like to be an Adams or
particularly the Addams family had a
habit of picking one Adams progeneration
and then dumping all of their
expectations on that one.
Adams clearly John Quincy Adams is
this generation's guy. So there's,
this certainly gives you a
sense of, I want to say dead
hand of the past, I guess.
I guess it's the live hand of the past
because it's his father, this poor guy.
Like anything his father does,
he's clearly like, oh damn,
I have to be president too.
She's amazing. Um, but concrete,
a concrete example of what
I'm talking about here. Um,
and it certainly shows how the next
generation beyond the founding generation
really felt like they had to live up to
the achievements of what had gone before
them. Now, as far as the people
who had gone before them,
as far as the fathers are concerned,
they knew that they were becoming history.
And so they thought about the making of
history and the writing of history a lot.
To me the most, the most
concrete example, um,
of people becoming history is something
that happened to poor Thomas Jefferson
in his old age. You know, I wonder if any
of you ever seen a life mask. You know,
there's death masks in life masks,
death masks are obvious,
but there do exist life masks as
well. So again, Jefferson's old age,
someone went to Monte Cello and they
wanted to make a life mask of him.
I don't know who this guy
was, but he wasn't good at
his job. So whatever he did,
he did it wrong. And his,
his daughter later said,
she came into the room to see
the guy with a hammer and chisel,
like trying to chip the plaster. You're
like, oh my God, I killed him, you know,
like the plaster hardened
and they couldn't get it off.
So Jefferson's like basically thinking
this is so bad, this is really bad.
He really like was terrified
that that was the end for him.
He literally almost became history.
He was his dream. He was gone.
Luckily they can pick out the
plaster off and, and he survived.
But aside from the fact that he
almost melted into plaster, um,
obviously that whole cohort of people had
really strong feelings about the story
of the revolution,
about how that story should be told.
And they were not in love with the whole
idea that the founding period is some
kind of golden age of
patriotic perfection.
They did not see the revolution is some
kind of divine strike of Providence.
They did not see themselves as demi gods.
And here I'm going to turn to John
Adams, which always makes me happy. Um,
who did a really good job in his old age
of answering letters from strangers who
wanted to know,
tell us about the revolution,
what really happened and an answering.
He did a great job of basically
popping bubbles of myths, you know, he,
he basically said over and over again
in one way or another, you know,
revolution wasn't some kind of
golden, wonderful moment. Now,
like the other founders,
he actually lived to be 90,
so unfortunately he had a lot of
these letters. Um, I think Jefferson,
I think I was back to say
Jefferson I think got more,
which obviously would
make Adam's really mad.
Like even now I was thinking
about him more than me. Um,
but I think all of these guys were getting
these letters from people basically
in one way or another saying, you know,
tell us what was it really like? Like,
what was it like, what happened when you
signed the declaration? What happened?
What was it really like? Jefferson in
particular was driven crazy. I mean,
Jefferson Jefferson doesn't normally
emote on paper in a deep kind of sincere,
like he's not thinking hard way.
They always get a sense,
he's thinking really carefully
about how he expresses himself. Um,
but when he's riding to Adam's
in their old age, he gets,
he's really just sort of Vince about
this whole like strangers writing letters
and asking about history thing.
So he says he complains from sunrise to
one or two o'clock and often from dinner
to dark,
I am dredging at the writing table and
all this to answer letters into which
neither interest nor
inclination on my part enters.
And often for persons whose names I have
never before heard. And in this letter,
Jefferson estimates that an 1822 he
got 1,267 of these letters from people,
just strangers.
Tell us about the declaration.
He called it the burden of his life.
And then at one point in this letter,
and this is where I felt like he really
hit like Jeffersonian bottom, he's,
he's like whining and whining and he's
going on, I hate this, I hate this. Well,
they stop, you know, probably out
of the thinking sends them to me.
I have something to say.
Um,
but finally at this point in the
letter Jefferson just writes,
is this life it's so
weirdly modern. You know,
that's like something we have probably
all said at one point is this life,
please stop writing me the letters.
His life actually got worse on this front.
You got it. You're feeling
bad for the founders here. Um,
people didn't just like daily
gym with random letters.
Strangers made pilgrimages to Monte Cello.
It became like a tourist attraction
and he was still living in it.
And so strangers would come
and just swarm around macho,
like peering in the window, you know,
like, oops, I broke the glass, you know,
like trampoline the car.
And he got so overwhelmed by this that
he basically after a while left my cello
and lived in one of his other homes
for a while. Like I just can't take it.
I'm abandoning my house to the strangers.
I'm going to go live in my
other house for a little while.
And that's why actually those of you
who've been to mount a cello and you've
seen his little sanctuary,
there's a look,
a little area that's really his and has
sort of all his books and his bed and
it's really their doors that
can lock it off to everything,
which is really rare for a
real reason because that was,
that literally was his sanctuary. That was
like the swarms are outside lock, lock,
lock, lock, like you're
not coming in. So I think,
I think it wasn't fun being a founder
and basically that's what Jefferson is
showing us here. Um, but whether or
not they were happy old founders,
the founding types who are
answering these letters,
we're really trying to shape the telling
of the history of the revolution and
different founders I'm sure had different
messages and some are probably happier
than others or more
optimistic than others.
I think James Madison was like
optimistic to the end. Um, Adams,
as I said before,
spent a lot of time sort of punching
holes and myths about the revolution that
already were circulating in
the 18 teens in the 1820s.
So over and over and over again,
he told people that there had not been
some kind of unanimous, patriotic,
glorious moment as it seemed to have
been looking from the distance of time.
So in response to one letter,
he insisted that the revolution was not
a big wave of unanimous patriotism as he
put it.
Every measure of Congress from 1774
to 1787 inclusively was disputed with
acrimony and decided by a small majorities
as any question is decided these
days. Right. I saying, you know, it's
not like we were like, yes, independence.
You say,
you know,
sometimes it was like one or two votes
that we decided this and then it goes out
into history and all the people know is
we voted yes and it seems unanimous and
it really wasn't even iconic.
Revolutionary moments he thought should
not be viewed as the sort of blurry is
moments of triumph.
He in one letter he recalled what he
was thinking as he watched people,
his fellow congressmen signed the
Declaration of Independence and he said,
I could not see their hearts,
but as far as I could penetrate the
intricate foldings of their souls.
I then believed and have not
since altered my opinion,
that there were several who signed with
regret and several others with many
doubts and much lukewarmness.
He said, he's saying, okay,
even while they're like signing
the declaration, it's like,
I don't think some of these
people actually really
want it to be signing it at
all.
And some of them I think kind of wish
they were somewhere else not signing it,
which is not the image that's floating
around at this point about what the
revolution was.
So people were disagreeing.
He's saying back in the revolutionary era,
they came to the majority.
They weren't sure about
what they were doing.
They didn't even like what they were doing
sometimes and their decisions weren't
always good. He out. Of course. That's
something to say about that as well.
So he said in a different letter,
I say,
we did not make more mistakes
now than we did in 1770456789.
He's clearly making a point here.
When I was copying this, I was like,
how many more?
(808) 018-0280 three it's like,
I get your point. We made a lot of
mistakes through the whole revolution.
He's saying it was patched and Piebald
then as it is now and ever will be world
without end,
nor were battlefields any more sank.
Sacrosanct is Adam put it.
Adam's put it.
We blundered at Lexington at bunker's
hill where indeed did we not blunder
except Saratoga and Yorktown
where our triumphs redeemed.
All former disgraces.
So Adams is insisting much of the time,
you know,
we weren't all that great like
we made mistakes back then.
We didn't always entirely
believe what we were doing.
It wasn't that different
from how it is now.
The Revolution was not some golden age
of perfection and Adam summed all of this
up in a letter that I like
because in some way, I don't know.
It seems a little more direct than
some of these other letters and it,
if it was a while,
you'll hear the way he phrases it.
He wrote this letter in 1811 and he
said to this one correspondent who said,
you know, I revere the fathers,
I, you know, I want to be
like them. Oh, you know,
all the things he's getting in
all of these letters. And he says,
I ought not to object to your
reverence for your fathers,
but to tell you to tell you a great
secret as far as I am capable of comparing
the merit of different periods.
I have no reason to believe
we were better than you are.
He has like being really
straight forward about this.
Now all of those quotes of course are
from the sort of lofty Adams, you know,
the far seeing items, the sage
Adams, they're not from the Adams.
I was just referring to a few minutes ago,
which is the, I don't get any respect.
John Adams and he's there too and mean.
Both of those things were there at the
same time, which also tells you something.
When you read the
correspondence of his old age,
he sort of veering back and forth between,
I am a lofty founder.
Why won't anyone recognize me as a lofty
founder? I'm a lefty founder, please.
Someone recognized me. He has all these
letters where he's like, you know,
no one will ever make a monument to me.
John Adams,
so sorry,
but my,
my point here is that to
Adams and to many others,
you're not supposed to look at
history as this sort of golden,
perfect moment that's drastically
different in that sense,
from everything since innocence to these
people worshiping the founding era or
worshiping the American revolution as a
golden age actually did more harm than
good. The revolution had
been all about beginnings,
about beginning traditions
and patterns of governance,
about beginning new constitutions.
But these beginnings were
actually supposed to go
someplace they were supposed
to lead to something that actually
would survive and be shaped by future
generations.
So I think to this whole generation,
this idea of sort of worshiping
the founding era as a
golden age made it seem as
though the time for that kind of work
had ended as though there was a glorious,
wonderful creative moment when things
could be done. Uh, now that time is gone.
And you could see that in Adam's letters
to that he says often about the future.
Well, you know, maybe it
will be a brighter page or
maybe it'll be a darker page.
I don't know.
It's up to you.
But he assumes obviously that what they've
been doing isn't some like dead end
moment at which who knows
what will happen next.
He actually assumes they've started
something that in one way or another,
they assume it's going to continue.
So clearly the time for that kind of
creative political work hadn't ended
whenever the random date is that we
decide the American revolution ended.
And in a sense it hasn't ended
as the founding generation. Well,
new American citizens are always
responsible for their government.
They control its destiny, right?
They decide when revolutions start,
they decide when revolution stop,
they control the destiny of
the aftereffect of revolutions.
So I guess in a sense, and this is where
I was really struggling this morning,
I was like, what would be the
ultimate message I give to you?
It's so hard when you teach courses on
the founding period because everything
you say has weird
resonance in the present.
As I'm kind of saying here and I
don't want to have weird resonance,
I just want to sort of give
something to you guys. Um,
so related to what I'm saying here,
maybe the ultimate message of the sort
of ground level message or this course is
your opinions matter and your actions
out there in the world politically and
otherwise are going to matter too.
That's in essence what these founders are
saying when they're saying don't treat
us like demi gods,
like where some lofty population
that will never come again.
Then when we set something in motion
and the whole point of the thing that we
set in motion is that you're
supposed to make it run, right.
It's actually about you.
We may be memorable guys.
I might want to be a more memorable
guy than I am, but it's all about you.
It's all about you. That's what's supposed
to keep it running in the end. Okay. Um,
I want to, first of all, thank you
for laughing at my jokes all semester.
Obviously,
one of my favorite things to do is to
tell stories and lecture courses are
moments where you're completely my
hostage and I get to it sometimes as I'm
writing a lecture, as as today,
I'm like, oh, this isn't related,
but I'll find a way to rope it in to the
lecture so then I can give it to you.
So I have greatly enjoyed myself
this semester. You've been,
you've been wonderfully receptive.
You asked, when I went to sections,
you asked wonderful questions, you're
engaged with the material. After lectures,
you guys kept coming up to
me and asking good questions,
which was impressive and doesn't
always happen in electric cords.
So I want to thank you because it makes
me really happy if you guys are really
engaged with what I'm talking about here.
So thank you very much.
[inaudible].